so we've already discussed today
that donald trump's actions on just
about every issue everything we see him
do publicly
it's motivated at least partially by
does it hurt him in november or does it
help him in november that's the lens
through which
all of these decisions are being made
about carrying his mask around
about cancelling the huge event of the
republican national convention all of
this stuff is just what's the calculus
in terms of how it affects my election
when it comes to vote by mail we just
received
some stunning new polling data from
emerson polling
and if this data doesn't convince you
that trump knows
exactly what he's doing by opposing vote
by mail and confusing vote by mail with
absentee voting
as if they're two different things this
data should convince you
that he knows exactly what he is doing
poll subjects were asked
in this emerson polling survey who they
support
trump versus biden and grouped by
whether they plan to vote in person or
vote by mail
of those who plan to vote in person
65 support trump and
only 32 percent support joe biden
of those who plan to vote absentee
76 percent support joe biden
and only 20 support donald trump so put
it a different way
trump leads two to one among voters
planning to vote in person
and biden leads almost four to one among
people planning to vote by mail
this is why trump opposes vote by mail
now
the thing to understand is that this
split between in-person versus vote by
mail
is not partisan per se it's health
related
let me explain what i mean we know from
other polling
that republicans are roughly half as
likely as democrats
to wear masks all the time when they
leave their house i think it was
something like
roughly 66 to 33 or you know 66 percent
of democrats were wearing a mask all the
time outside their house
only 33 percent of republicans or
something like that
what this means is democrats are taking
the pandemic
more seriously the reason that biden
supporters are way likely
way more likely to vote by mail is they
are taking the risk
of catching coronavirus more seriously
than republicans
now you could come in and say well if
there's more vote by mail open more
trump supporters will vote by mail
if there's less vote by mail open biden
supporters
will just go and vote in person it's all
going to shake out evenly
that's exactly the wrong approach
that is exactly the mistake that's being
made in analyzing this
biden voters are more likely not to vote
at all if they can't do it safely
while trump voters are more likely to
vote in person
if that's available if that's all that's
available so
sure most biden voters planning to vote
by mail
if they are told you can't vote by mail
they'll put a mask on
they understand the importance they'll
go and
take the risk because they understand
the importance of the election
but if you believe as is probably the
case that there are
some biden supporters who might not vote
at all if they can't vote absentee
you then try to stop vote by mail
altogether which is exactly what donald
trump is doing
imagine that if you take some state that
could be close
and you restrict cancel or stop vote by
mail
and it dissuades just three percent of
the total electorate from voting
and imagine that in that three percent
who will say
if i can't vote by mail i'm not voting
at all imagine that
80 of that slice would have voted for
biden
and 20 of that slice would have voted
for donald trump
that can flip a state that it literally
is enough to flip a state let's look at
wisconsin in 2016. now
trump won wisconsin in 2016 very
narrowly trump won by about 22 000 votes
in 2016 in wisconsin if you dissuade
three percent
from voting that's about 83 000 people
that you would dissuade from voting
maybe if you say you have to come in in
person
if 80 of those dissuaded or biden
supporters
and 20 of those dissuaded are trump
supporters
canceling vote by mail grows trump's
victory by
fifty thousand votes now the margin was
only twenty two thousand so
understand how a small portion of the
electorate
if it is mostly biden supporters being
dissuaded
from voting could flip or put a state
out of reach now
this is a hypothetical example with
hypothetical numbers the point
is blocking vote by mail
even if it affects a small percentage of
total voters
based on this data it would
disproportionately hit
biden supporters and it could turn a
state so when you combine
trying to prevent vote by mail with
kneecapping the post office which is
what donald trump is doing right
now by having selected one of his donors
to be postmaster general
you can actually turn states and that's
why you know when we see
okay one poll has biden winning by 15
it's not going to be 15
another poll has biden winning by 10 but
when you account for the margin of error
it might only be six
if that six becomes three or four by
election day
if you strategically slow down the mail
in some states
and stop vote by mail in other states
a three or four percent popular vote
victory for
joe biden might not be enough to
actually win
electorally with hillary we know 2.2 as
a or 2.8 2.2
as an as a popular vote win was not
enough to win electorally because of 77
000 votes in three states
we could see that again and this is why
anybody who's looking at the polling and
saying
we got this we got this biden's up 15.
biden might only be up six or five when
you account for the margins of error
and that could very quickly become an
electoral college loss because of
exactly
this stuff do not become complacent is
the message
continue uh uh we will continue our
coverage of this on the david pakman
show instagram page
at david pakman show follow me on
instagram
for my latest argentinian food delivery
from this weekend got some really great
stuff empanadas of course
of course empanadas i'm david.pakman on
instagram we'll take a quick break and
be right back